tonight James Earl is in London
performing Driving Miss Daisy with
Vanessa Redgrave and Boyd Gaines but the
Academy is not about to let 5,000 miles
get in the way of a good time so please
return to the screen your attention to
the screen as we take you to the Windham
Theatre in London's West End to see what
happened at the end of Driving Miss
Daisy this very afternoon
Oh tonight in Los Angeles the Academy of
Motion Pictures and Arts and Sciences
will be announcing three honorary Oscars
and one of them is for James R
that's just the beginning hooray
because as James Earl Jones is here at
the Windham Theatre in London and the
ceremony is tonight
in Los Angeles the Academy have arranged
for a very special ceremony here on this
stage and now will you join Boyd games
and me in giving a big welcome to the
actor who's going to present Jim with
his Oscar Academy Award winner Sir Ben
Kingsley
[Applause]
even before I met James Earl Jones I
I felt that I knew him there's a
familiarity about his every aspect his
imposing physical presence his one
thousand kilowatt smile and his Basso
profundo voice with which he is graced
some of the best loved characters in
cinema behind and something I envy a
mask of great stillness yet our craft is
symbolized by two masks the mask of
tragedy and the mask of comedy and James
you inhabit them both so brilliantly
from Star Wars to Shakespeare from dr.
Strangelove to The Lion King
you you achieve what every actor strives
for let me put it simply you're always
so damn good
from animated films arthouse films
blockbusters comedy-drama period films
you grace every performance with an
astonishing professionalism a passionate
honesty and a deeply rooted and unique
humanity which all of us have witnessed
watching and all of us witness working
with you on behalf of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences it is
my joy and my privilege to present you
James Earl Jones with this an Academy
Award
thank you
I know
you've been very kind to stay with us
you're a great audience this afternoon I
just want to ask you a question if an
actor's nightmare is being onstage buck
naked and not knowing his lines what the
heck do you call this I've been on this
stage with a great audience and thank
you and I had my clothes on
I knew my words and then out from the
wings cepsa Ben Kingsley and he has made
Hofstra frankly frankly what the heck
else would you call that but an actor's
wet dream
and aside from that how do I feel well
I'm more than flabbergasted there's a
wood I've learned here in Britain they
say I'm gobsmacked and that's the only
word that I can think of that's
appropriate for this our improbable
moment in my life
improbable because well let's start with
my introduction to motion pictures four
years old sitting on a bench in the dark
in Mississippi to school to storekeepers
have taken a bedsheet and stretch it
between those stores one sells popcorn
the other cells sort of pop that
familiar and when those images start
emitting sound on that bed sheet and the
shootouts and the fisticuffs start I
simply can't handle it and I dive under
the bench in terror begging screaming
make them stop somebody make them stop
doing that
well I can't make them stop so
eventually I joined them and for a half
a century now being a gentleman after in
my own fashion I still spend more time
on boards like these than in front of
cameras like I had sometimes feel like
that lone wolf
lurking around the outside that glow the
cinema campfire lurching in the snatch
morsel of movie now and then now
sometimes those muscles I'm quite proud
of but you cannot be a cinema actor and
conduct your
like I've done and not end up in some of
the worst movies ever committed to
celluloid but I want to tell you
something what I wanna I want to tell
you I'm I so cherish them that I refuse
to name them you'll just have to Google
my friends because the night belongs to
Oscar I want to thank the the Academy
the Board of Governors I want to thank
you mr. Sid Ganis for flying my little
golden friend over the ocean and thank
you sir Ben Kingsley for presenting it
to me
ladies and gentlemen I stand before you
deeply honored mighty grateful and just
plain gobsmacked
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]